hi I'm Eric vos and a Pinterest
infinitive or left us with a lot of
questions a lot of them beginning with
the word why for example spoiler warning
why erase spider-man a black panther
when they're clearly gonna be the next
stars of the MCU why fuss so much of her
destroy visions mine stone if dannis
could just rewind their efforts with the
time stone anyway
why is Gamora I mean that's really the
central question anyway one big question
that we've been asking is who
specifically survived and who faded into
dust when Thanos snapped his fingers now
we saw which of the main Marvel heroes
weren't feeling so good but what about
all the wonderful supporting characters
off screen well recently the directors
the Russo brothers reveal the fates of
many of those other major in Cu
characters so let's run through what we
now know when what this might tell us
about the next Avengers movie okay first
let's look at the people in the world of
spider-man Peter Parker the directors
marked Aunt May's safe but they said Ned
Leeds Peters best friend has an unknown
fate that was too much of a spoiler to
reveal to me this sounds like the next
Avengers movie we'll check in with the
grieving Aunt May dear and if Ned Leeds
faded away someone like MJ could play a
major role or if Ned is still alive that
whole spoiler status could refer to him
playing an active role in the movies
story possibly as I've suggested before
to try to use Peters tech himself or to
connect with Miles Morales a character
that was established in this universe
and spider-man homecoming Donald Glover
played Aaron Davis smiles as uncle in
the comics and Aaron referenced his
nephew in a scene
I don't want those weapons in his
neighborhood I got a nephew Olivia but
let's move on and look at the supporting
characters of Black Panther T'Challa the
directors marked in the Kia Lupita
nyong'o's character as safe saying she
was on an undercover mission during the
events of infinity war meanwhile they've
suggested that sharees fate was staying
mystery that was too much of a spoiler
to discuss and again as in the case with
Ned I think this suggests Shuri will
play a very active role in Avengers 4
that's just too hard to talk about
without spoiling anything what idea is
that she could pick up the Black Panther
mantle with a vibranium suit of her own
which yeah is something that has
happened in the comics after all guys
without to chala around what Conda in
the world still needs someone to carry
on the Black Panther name and in my
opinion his sister Shuri is the best
candidate okay let's look at the
supporting characters around Thor what
happened to all those odd balls from
Ragnarok well the Russos refused to
reveal Corgan Nixon
but marblehead Kevin Feige has said that
he has big plans for them so I think we
can assume that they will return and I
think Valkyrie is in that same boat
infinity war Thor told the Guardians
that Thanos killed half of the Asgardian
refugees so I'm guessing that these
three were in that safe half I also
think we should assume that Thanos says
snap did not apply to the civilizations
that he had already killed half of
actually it's possible that that is part
of these soul stones powers maybe Thanos
could use it to identify which of the
creatures across the universe to
eliminate half of and which that he
already checked the box for but
interestingly the Russos also said that
Jane Foster's fate is too much of a
spoiler to reveal she's curious because
thor ragnarok seemed to write Natalie
Portman's character out of the series
sorry I hear that Jane dumps you she
didn't dump me you know does mutual
dumping so really saying anything about
Jane Foster's fate suggests her name
will come up again perhaps Thor will
learn that she faded away in the snap
wave and that will further motivate his
vengeance against Thanos maybe enough
that he'll actually aim for the head
this time meanwhile the ruse has
confirmed that Lady SIF who played major
roles in the first Thor and Thor the
dark world is gone now she was away for
the events of Thor Ragnarok the actress
was shooting a different TV show now
apparently Lady SIF was among the half
of the universe that faded and by the
way the same goes for the Asgardian
actor who played Loki in the play and
Ragnarok is played by Matt Damon he's
even to be feeling good about himself at
the curtain call now not feeling that
good sadly these same fate goes for
Betty Ross Bruce banners love interest
played by Liv Tyler in the Incredible
Hulk now a lot of the characters in that
movie haven't really been in the picture
now that the MC has moved on with Mark
Ruffalo Bruce Banner other than Biggs
dad old Thunderbolt Ross but yeah both
Thor and Hulk lost the ex-girlfriends in
the snap wave maybe they already moved
on but yeah it's still an awkward thing
for them to learn oh damn do I do I do
anything sorry I let her get away and
the Russos were also nice enough to let
us know that Howard the Duck is still
alive and well for all the millions of
fans asking but there are still other
characters whose fates we still don't
know Pepper Potts I'm assuming is still
okay given winneth pouch Rose cryptic
interview comments that have led some
fans to speculate that of interest for
could begin with a time jump in a little
Stark baby but remember there's also
happy hogan who's
absence could be a personal motivating
force for Tony to further when to avenge
Thanos as genocide we also have yet to
see what will happen with ant-man Scott
Lang and his related community Hank Pym
hope Van Dyne in the original wasp Janet
Van Dyne as well as Scott's daughter
Cassie hopefully we'll see what happens
to these folks when Amy and the wasp
comes out in July but we also know that
Hawkeye clint barton will be returning
in Avengers for set photos showing his
new look has suggested that he may have
turned into the Ronin version of the
character from the comics just more of a
moody loner there's one theory going
around that's saying that he's going
down that path because the people in his
world his wife Laura and their kids
could have tragically faded in that snap
oh man so dark just picture that haunted
Punisher Hawkeye the Barton farm
littered with rage arrows a question for
you guys when it comes to these
supporting characters are you more
excited to see them alive to help the
fight against Thanos or absent to make
the surviving Avengers more motivated to
fight harder comment with your thoughts
down below or you can tweet me directly
at EA Voss or parley new rockstars on
Twitter for updates on our videos like
and share this video and subscribe to
new rock stars for all of our deep dives
into Avengers infinity war in the MCU
and if you really like this channel you
can contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our donors especially
William Holtz thanks for watching bye
[Music]